pues vaya desde las autoridades del
gobierno viajaron esta jornada hasta
arica al complejo fronterizo de
chacalluta entre ellos el ministro del
interior subrogante Manuel monsalve las
subsecretaría de relaciones exteriores
gloria de la Fuente Los subsecretarios
de Justicia defensa y se reunieron allá
con la policía y del delegado
presidencial para tomar una serie de
medidas entre ellas crear puntos de
registro civil para registrar aquellas
personas que salgan de chile para contar
con su fotografía sus huellas sus datos
también puntos de atención porque
monsalve afirma que los inmigrantes no
conocen la realidad de chile y de Perú
entre otras medidas monsalve también
afirmó que están ahí para como gobierno
Buscar soluciones a una crisis y no para
crear conflictos la subsecretaría de
relaciones exteriores gloria de la
Fuente realizó un comunicado en el que
se afirma que siguen manteniendo
comunicado con conversaciones con el
gobierno de Perú algo que llevan
haciendo desde hace varias semanas que
se Confía en la vía del diálogo y que
sean estas conversaciones han sido
fructíferas en las últimas horas pero
que la solución es también pasan por
otros países en concreto aquellos países
a las que las personas quieren volver
puesto que son sus lugares de origen en
relación a Venezuela bueno Patricia y
precisamente por esa vuelta quería
preguntarte por qué están regresando
muchos de estos migrantes a sus países
de origen
pues son varias las razones en las que
argumentan muchas de las personas que se
encuentran en esa frontera entre ellos
por ejemplo el incremento de la vida El
puesto de la vida en Chile que afecta
especialmente aquellas poblaciones más
vulnerables que tienen menores recursos
también la dificultad para muchos de
ellos de poder alquilar lugares sin
tener documentos recordemos que muchos
de ellos entraron a través de la misma
frontera porosa en el norte que no
tienen documentación y que el proceso
para legalizar su situación en el país
para conseguir los documentos es
bastante tedioso es largo muchos de
ellos también se han visto afectados por
la medida que anunció la fiscalía en las
últimas semanas de que cualquier persona
que sea
cualquier persona que sea detenida
podría ir a prisión de forma preventiva
realizando cualquier tipo de delito
también en algo especialmente destinado
a aquellos migrantes que detienen y no
tienen documentación y eso ha generado
también una serie de reacciones en una
comunidad que también en las últimas
jornadas ha visto como se ha endurecido
el discurso desde algunos lugares por
ejemplo en estos momentos en el congreso
se tramita una ley
se aprobó por parte de comisión y se
envió al congreso una ley que
penalizaría aquellas personas que llegan
al país de forma clandestina por pasos
irregulares y que no tienen
documentación el clima ha ido creciendo
en estas últimas semanas especialmente
desde la muerte de un tercer carabinero
en menos de un mes algo que ha
incrementado mucho los discursos de
seguridad y también los discursos anti
inmigración